مهرجان الرافدين السينمائي قدم لجمهوره
وعلى مدى يومين 69 فيلما من العراق و 20
دوله عربيه واجنبيه النسخه الثانيه من
المهرجان السنوي حمله اسم الفنانه سناء
عبد الرحمن التي تحتفظ باكبر عدد من
البطولات المطلقه في تاريخ السينما
العراقيه
من الخارج وبالتالي مصدر لشبابنا حتى
يتعرفوا على السينما بره والان تطور
الصباح بالنسبه للصوره بالنسبه للاخراج
غير ما كان قبل سابقا
من خلال مجد الجسور التواصل مع ما ينتج
السينمائيا في العالم
نتواصل مع العالم
ونسبه للعالم بان العراق يقف على قدميه لا
سيما في مجال الثقافه والفن والسينما
اللجان ايضا لجان دوليه من العراق وسوريا
والمغرب يكون من مخرجاتها تر 69 فيلما من
20 دوله تنافس على الجوائز الرسميه
للمهرجان الرسميه للمهرجان حصدتها ثمانيه
افلام اربعه منها اجنبيه
واربعون عربيه
انا سعيده جدا انني يعني جئت لاول مره الى
بغداد يعني من خلال هذا الفيلم تعرفت على
الشعب الطيب الشعب الكريم والحمد لله لقد
فزت همم بجائزه لجنه التحكيم
ببغداد في محاوله للتقدم خطوه باتجاه كسر
الانماط التقليديه في تقديم العروض
السينمائيه